[Music]
self-conscious spirit that has withdrawn
into itself from the shapeless essence
or has raised its immediacy to self in
general
determines its unitary nature as a
manifoldness of being for self
and is the religion of spiritual
perception
in this it falls apart into the
numberless multiplicity of weaker and
stronger
richer and poorer spirits this pantheism
which to begin with is the passive
subsistence of all these spiritual atoms
develops into a hostile movement within
itself the
innocence of the flower religion which
is merely the selfless idea of self
gives place to the earnestness of
warring life to the guilt
of animal religions the passivity and
omnip
and impotence of contemplative
individuality
pass into destructive being for self
it is of no use to have taken from the
things of perception
the deadness of abstraction and to have
raised them to beings
of spiritual perception the insolent of
this kingdom of spirits
bears this death within it owing to the
determinateness and the negativity which
encroach
upon the innocent indifference of plant
life
through this negativity the dispersion
into the multiplicity of passive plant
forms because
becomes a hostile movement in which the
hatred
which stems from being for self is
aroused the
actual self-consciousness of this
dispersed spirit
is a host of separate antagonistic
national spirits
which who hate and fight each other to
the death
and become conscious of specific forms
of animals
as their essence for they are nothing
else
than animal spirits animal lives which
separate themselves off from one another
and are unconscious of their
universality
paragraph 689 begins another
subsection in the natural religion
portion
of the religion section and it's titled
plant and animal and it's
used in the singular there so dostia
right even though we have
many animals there's a multiplicity and
plurality even
with the plants but it's even more so
with the animals and when you're reading
this section
it's natural to try to say well what is
hegel
actually referencing here in this
development of religious
forms religious ways of
approaching spirit self-consciousness
the divine
and there's there's certain aspects i
think it's very helpful
to go back to that that previous
paragraph
in the beginning of the natural religion
section where he says listen there's
every religion has more or less all of
the dimensions or aspects
some are being highlighted and others
are being
downplayed or less essential so we could
think about
maybe not just single religions but
attitudes within religions that exhibit
this
and we could also ask ourselves a
further question which hegel isn't
asking about this with the religions
that he considers
much more developed that we're getting
to later in the phenomenology
do they exhibit this sort of
dialectic happening and that's that's
sort of an open
question another thing that i think is
is normal for people wanting to go
through this section
is to say okay where else does hegel
talk about
this sort of stuff and the natural place
to go to is his lectures on the
philosophy of religion and there's not
an awful lot
pertaining to this at least in the
natural religion section of those
lectures the closest thing that we get
to it is
in his consideration of indian religion
primarily hinduism
where he talks about you know a
multiplicity of natural aspects but
there it's not just plants and animals
it's also
natural phenomena like the moon or the
sun
and so we don't have exactly the same
sort of development
going on and you could ask yourself well
why
why is this section here and i think
we'll put that answer
off to the following paragraph this is a
very very short section
only two paragraphs and we'll so we'll
we'll approach that where it's a little
bit more natural
because of the the transition there is a
transition here as well
and it's a transition that happened in
the previous very short paragraph
of the last subsection in which
we have this you know shapeless essence
of light dispersing itself in
life which is itself a
multiplicity so that's that's a good
place to begin
and we should remind ourselves that this
the entirety of this is self-conscious
spirit
or spirit conscious of self and is that
the same thing
well yes but if we if we reformulate it
as
conscious of self we could also say
conscious through self
it is a question of the self of the
spirit
that is being manifested here
so uh what we have happening here
there there's uh two previous sections
that are coming up actually there's
three previous sections when you think
about it
and one of them is is quite explicitly
he talks about perception
um and that's you know what followed
after send certainty which he referenced
just just earlier we also
have the sort of invocation
of the self-consciousness section both
in terms of like the multiplicity of
life
and particularly animal life and then
this
this war including a struggle to the
death
between different self consciousnesses
right
and i think we can also without going
too far
reference the spiritual animal kingdom
as well and in each of these we're
dealing with multiplicity and figuring
out where
where is the dialectical development
where is what's really
essential to what's going on where is
meaning in a full sense so he says
self-conscious spirit that is withdrawn
into itself from the shapeless essence
right the gestalt losses vasen
or has raised its immediacy to into self
in general
determines its unitary nature as a
manifoldness of being for self and you
can say how how do you determine a
unitary nature
as something that is manifold or a
multiplicity well uh that's exactly what
it what it means it's determining itself
uh not just as a single unitary thing
but
it's it's unfolding if we want to
continue this folding metaphor
into a whole bunch of other selves
right and he says this is the religion
of spiritual perception so
why bring up perception here well in
perception one of the things that we
were trying to grapple with was
the thing and its properties and we
understood the thing and its properties
the properties in relation to each other
they have a little bit more
substantiality
than just being accidents of something
or predicates of something and then we
understood the thing in relation to
other things
and the predicates as general and
covering different things so something
similar is going to be
happening behind the scenes here he goes
on and he says that
it falls apart into the numberless
multiplicity
and here he he invokes a couple
important qualifications
and i think we're thinking more or less
about the end point here
with the flower religion sort of in the
process
uh a multiplicity of weaker and stronger
richer and poorer spirits what are the
what are the weaker
the flower religion and some of the
animal religions what are the richer
the animal religions as opposed to
flower religion
and we'll talk about that in just a
moment so he says
this pantheism and he uses the word
pontius
the ismos there right which to begin
with is the passive
subsistence of these spiritual atoms now
is he trying to define
pantheism in general no this is not a
discourse on that
we'll talk about why pantheism but but
what's really important here
is that he says it's a passive
subsistence
of these spiritual atoms the things that
are individuated
are you know sort of like the basic
components
and they're they are passive they don't
do anything by themselves right
as opposed to the animal uh religions
that we're going to see
so how is this pantheism well everything
is divine everything
has divinity within it everything is
part of this great
perspective in which everything is is
god
and he brings up um well before we get
to the flower religion he says
it develops into a hostile movement
within itself does it do so in the
flower religion
no because that's passivity it does so
in terms of the animal religion or
religions
as we're going to look at in a moment
and this is where the real uh
of this this section is the plant is is
actually kind of like a
it's a stepping stone it doesn't he
doesn't he's not interested
in examining that for its own sake here
he does tell us some things about it he
calls it the innocence of the flower
religion so it's not just plants in
general like a tree or something like
that the flower religion
now you know you could say and we're
going beyond the text here why flowers
well flowers
introduce a lot of interesting
what should we call them dimensions
right
not to say that other parts of plants
don't but
flowers have many different colors
within a world in which
you know there may be less color than
what we
are accustomed to because we have so
many manufacturing ways of introducing
all sorts of colors and we can have
pixels you know we can
do any effects we want you know the blue
of beautiful wildflowers and spring
is is really quite something you know
the
uh pink of wild dog roses
all of these sorts of things that's one
aspect the flower is also something that
if we think about the purpose of it it's
a way a plant reproduces itself
through a through a show through an
appearance um
you know they're really the sex organs
of the plant in in many respects
interestingly you know we give flowers
uh oftentimes as part of romantic
rituals right
where we compare people to flowers so
the flower religion
and how does he talk about it it's
innocent
right it doesn't have guilt uh it's
merely and then he says
merely the selfless idea of
self and this this is a little bit of a
okay i can see why miller uses the word
idea but i think it's it's kind of
misleading forced right that's a really
important term for hegel
for showing representation this
representation
that we are getting here is
a selfless representation of
self so there's something there's
something missing to it and the
passivity of it is part of it
he says the passivity and impotence of
contemplative individuality right
contemplative individuality nothing
wrong with contemplation
nothing wrong with individuality but
passivity and
impotence an incapacity to really do
anything
it's a way you know you think of the
beautiful soul in the previous
uh section of morality
what's the contrast to where is the
development going
he says that the passive subsistence
develops into a
hostile movement within itself and
that's a phrase that he uses several
times
uh feinzeliga right
a hostile approaching the other as an
enemy movement is just bevagoing the
typical hegelian term
for some sort of development and so
uh he says that the earnest the
innocence gives place to the earnestness
of
warring life that's over here
the guilt of animal religion so guilt
responsibility uh taking on
if you think about individuality you can
have individuality
in innocence and it's not really
completely individuality individuality
is when we take on
the responsibility
uh for the things that we choose which
damage which threaten other
beings whereas the flower religion it's
all
very you know nice and airy and stuff
like that so he goes on and he says
it's of no use to have taken from things
of perception the deadness of
abstraction and raise them to beings of
spiritual perception right that's the
animal kingdom
or the the flower uh religion the
insolent
given soul of this kingdom of spirits
bears this
death within it owing to the
determinateness and the negativity
which encroach upon the innocent
indifference of plant
life and so he says through this
negativity
the dispersion into this multiplicity of
past passive plant forms
becomes again we see this term hostile
movement
in which the hatred which stems from
being for
self is aroused now isn't that an
interesting thing to say
hatred hassa not just
temporary fighting hatred hatred for
other
beings also in a certain sense hatred
for
one's own being for herself which then
can be projected
outward in aggressivity to other beings
which then threatens them and they
threaten
you sounds a lot like the beginning of
the self-consciousness section doesn't
it
and this this word that he's using
aroused here is going to get translated
a little bit differently in the next
paragraph alfred right um
[Music]
so aroused here is is is uh
you could say they chafe each other in a
way
right they grind on each other and
they have to come into conflict and so
he tells us that
the actual self-consciousness the actual
self-consciousness involved
in animal religion the view click
zelps bavus sign what it is to be
a real self-consciousness a
self-conscious
being both as an individual and as we're
going to see
in groups or tribes or nations
he says the actual self-consciousness of
this dispersed spirit
it becomes what a host of
separate antagonistic national spirits
who hate and fight each other to the
death so we've got a lot there
right uh separate right separated off
from each other for shidna
antagonistic national spirits now we
shouldn't think necessarily of like
nation states
because this term philip you know in in
fuku
geister right folk means any sort of
ethnicity it's sort of like the greek uh
genos
there's other terms that that translated
as well
and it's any sort of group that has a
self-consciousness
of itself it could actually i think
be not just the consciousness of a
particular people
but even of a clan within that
particular people we could be talking
here
about totemic things where there's
tension between
identification with particular animals
and so he says that they
hate and fight each other to the death
they are willing uh to throw it all
onto the table and risk everything
unlike there's no risk here in
the flower religion everybody's nice to
each other i mean you could have like i
suppose
different contests about which flowers
are the prettiest or
who can pick the best ones but there
isn't that struggle going on there
the second part of this that's really
important at least as far as this
development goes he says become
conscious
of specific forms of animals
right tyr gestaltene saunders tear
gestalt and specific forms of animals
so it could be the ox it could be the
monkey could be the tiger it could be
the
the lion it could be the bull could be
the snake whatever it happens to be
as essence or essence is
right and he says they're nothing else
than animal spirits
animal lives which separate themselves
off from one another
and are unconscious of their
universality
this is quite interesting so the
reference to animal spirits this was a
term that was still in general use in
hegel's time
and it means spirits basically compounds
within ourselves
that carry out movement and are
responsible for
our thinking and emotions
and how we move our limbs there were a
lot of theories of that we've we've long
since rejected that but
that was part of the understanding i
mean you look at descartes
passions of the soul and the explanation
of how the
brain and the the mind
connect up with each other the animal
spirits are part of the picture here
hegel's not using it in the
individualistic sense but saying this is
this is stuff that drives people
by the way you'll still see stock
brokers talking about animal spirits for
you know why the market moves the way
that it is because they don't have any
sort of
reasonable explanation so the the animal
spirits here
are things that one can identify with in
doing so
one is involved in this struggle against
other animal spirits and the
like he says the universality gets lost
in the process i
am just from this group
which identifies with the eagle or this
group which identifies with
the rabbit or pick whatever else you
want the earthworm
um we don't see an awful lot of worship
of earthworms but
you know people it's sort of like sports
teams right people usually seem to pick
the
the animals that draw our attention and
seem kind of tough right you don't see
the uh
bennington bunnies or something like
that i mean the mighty ducks okay ducks
are kind of a
a weak creature in general unless you
try to grab one and then you'll find out
so a lot you know long story short what
do we have here this this development of
this
warring um set of of
tribes or peoples who identify with a
particular animal
as against another animal
and they understand themselves as in
this hostile
relationship with uh what it is that
that
this tribe is worshiping and this tribe
is worshiping over here it's part of
their
their way of conceptualizing who they
are
in this hatred however the
determinateness of purely negative being
for self consumes itself
and through this movement of the notion
spirit enters into another shape
superseded being for self is the form of
the object a form
produced by the self or rather is the
produced self the self consuming self
that is the self that becomes a thing
the
artificer therefore retains the upper
hand over these mutually destructive
animal spirits
and his action is not merely negative
but tranquil and
positive spirits consciousness is thus
now
the movement which is above and beyond
the immediate in itself
as it is above and beyond the abstract
being for
self since the in itself is reduced
through opposition to being a
determinateness it is no longer the
proper form of absolute spirit
but a reality which its consciousness
finds confronting it as an
ordinary existent thing and which it
supersedes
at the same time this consciousness is
not only this being for self
which supersedes its object but it also
produces its own
idea the being for self that is put
forth in the form
of an object this productive activity
however is not
a perfect but a conditioned activity the
fashioning of a material
already to hand
paragraph 690 is beginning from the
starting point
of where the last paragraph left off
with this multiplicity
of animal religions each of which is
connected with a particular
group of people a folk right as their
spirits
as their their mentality uh this
corresponds to you know gaynos or ethnos
uh perhaps for for the greeks we could
think of all sorts of other things so
we're not
just tied to you know nations as such
but any sort of
group that has a self-conscious identity
and at this point in time
goes to war with other groups
understands itself
in relation not just to its own animal
that it identifies with
as perhaps we could say it's totem but
in relation to
its conflict and uh contradiction
of the the others and vice versa so
we've got this thing that he that he
calls hatred hassa right hatred between
a multiplicity
of animal and people's spirits and in
this section hegel's going to bring in
somebody new and we're at the cusp of
moving into
the next section which is just titled
the artificer
and hegel is is using um
a couple different terms in in this
section and
the section that's coming next so the
the uh
artificer in the chapter or the section
is actually the the varchmeister right
here it's a different term
uh the arbitenda and so
you know there's no sense of absolute
mastery
there um although there is you know
there is control there is a
they have the upper hand he says right
uh but this is focusing on the actual
activity this is not even
you know the arbeiter the the worker but
rather
the working one the one who is engaged
in
working and working on on what well
we're going to talk about the
object in just a moment so he says
in this hatred the determinateness of
purely negative being
for self consumes itself and through
this movement of the notion
spirit enters into another shape
superseded being for self as the form of
the object
a form produced by the self and now you
can say what in the hell is he talking
about there what does this have to do
with religion
so in the activity of representing
embodying whatever you want to call it
a certain animality a certain shape of
life
that consumes and contests with other
life the you know the the
in involved in this hatred and warfare
that's determinateness right
and this is what he's calling purely
negative being for self it's not
creating something new
something stable so he tells us that it
consumes itself and as i just mentioned
the previous paragraph
he's using this this term alfreiben
generally with zeke in in this case self
and here it's being translated as
consumes in the previous paragraph it
was translated as
arouses riben is to you know
rub on and so you could think about
chafing or wearing away
it's consuming itself not by devouring
itself
i mean if you want to think of devouring
think of what your molars do as opposed
to what your incisors
and canines do right it's not biting and
then swallowing
grinding away instead right so there's
this this process
and this is a super session or
auf heybong which comes up many times in
this
paragraph so he tells us that
superseded being for self is happening
because of this this
consuming itself and does this mean that
everything ends in terms of the animal
religions no but they need something
more stable something that would be
an object gegenstein something that
stands
over against you what might this be well
you know
the idol the representation
of the cult whether it be a giant statue
or whether it be something that you
carry around by yourself recently there
was discovered
just a beautiful tiny little cult statue
of an
owl you know dedicated to minerva in
some
purple um stone and it was
very nicely carved well this is the sort
of thing that we're talking about here
different different groups are
identifying themselves with different
animals
and so he talks about this being
superseded being for self
is the form of the object form of a
gegenstant
a form produced by the self right
before gabrakhta uh by by the self
it's just actually here for gabrakhta
there because uh he's going to use self
a little bit later
the self-consuming self right sick
alfreibanda
and then he talks about it as being the
the self that becomes a
thing and he uses the term ding there uh
so we've got object gegenstein and ding
thing right and this is something
that now has determinancy that you can
you can look at and say
aha i'm of the wolf tribe or clan or
group or whatever it happens to be
there's our wolf that's what it looks
like or maybe a whole bunch of wolves
because they they travel in packs or
something along those lines right and
and i mean this could be a cave
uh painting this could be all sorts of
things that have a material objective
presence now here's where he brings in
the artificer
because how do you get things well
you've got to have somebody to produce
them
and here is where he says the artificer
retains the upper hand over these
mutually destructive animal spirits and
his action is not merely negative
but tranquil and positive he
reintroduces positivity
and a kind of peacefulness into this or
a stability
into all of this and he goes and he says
spirits consciousness is thus now
the movement which is above and beyond
two things
the immediate in itself and the abstract
being for
self so it's above and beyond both of
these
since the in itself is reduced through
opposition to being determinateness
it is no longer the proper form of
absolute spirit but a reality
which its consciousness finds
confronting it as an ordinary existent
thing
and which it supersedes so you know this
isn't just
uh you know setting up a sort of
material artifact and then idolatry or
something like that
why because the artificer is there
as well to help give the
artificed the object which is
representing the animal spirits
something other than what they're
contributing the materiality
the form the uh dynamicity
and negative being for herself
he goes on and he says at the same time
this consciousness
is not only this being for self which
supersedes its object
right who's who's superseding the object
the artificer is
the artificer is uh introducing
something new
hey come look at this statue that i made
isn't this
awesome and cool and it represents what
you
yourself are saying is is vital to who
you are as a
people or group what you're going to
worship
so he says it also produces its own idea
now idea here foreshtelling
again we got to be a little bit careful
with this it's not an idea like a
concept
it's a representation or picture
thinking
is another way that miller often
translates for sterling
so that's it's producing being for self
in the form of an object now there's
also a kicker at the very end
this is a conditioned activity
not a perfect not a completely fulfilled
activity right
and what does that mean he says it's the
fashioning
of a material all ready to hand
something that is
available something that you take and
transform
its materiality into a new form of
materiality by
bringing form to it for miron right
activity tethy kite
right not not a deed but an ongoing
process
of doing things and so
there's an advance being made here in
terms of introducing
this entire realm of whatever it's going
to be something visible
something tangible that can be
grasped and now in this paragraph
hegel can turn us to directly
the artificer the vacmeister who is
going to take up the next eight
paragraphs
you